we know that the diamond is a gem we
know that it takes billions of years to
form the deep in the center of the earth
we know that it is beautiful expensive
and rare but diamond can serve another
purpose far beyond jewelry it may just
be that the diamond is the foundation of
a new era in computing performance if
people understood all of the
technological applications that are
possible with diamond jewelry of the
afterthought and truthfully one of those
applications is your smartphone over the
last few decades we've watched computing
power increase by leaps and bounds while
our devices miniaturized phones started
out the size of bricks but now they're
pencil thin with the operating
capabilities of the full computer but
that trend has one major impediment that
the very core of these power electronics
the temperature is actually the same as
on the Sun so electronics run
exceptionally hot Adam comm is the
founder and CEO of a con technologies
he's figured out how to use diamond as
an alternative to the current cooling
techniques diamond is actually able to
be incorporated directly on chip or you
won't need that same level of heat
sinking that same level of cooling heat
is the enemy of performance in
electronics it's also the enemy of
Psalms heat sinks are parts that are
added to devices to keep them from
overheating the problem is that these
heat sinks take up a lot of valuable
space we're at the point now where we
can't continue to make systems smaller
because we have to include these heat
sinking materials so very thick metals
on the bottom of these chips or cooling
fans attaching diamond directly onto
microchips eliminates the need for those
space hugging heat sinks it replaces
them and it does an even better job at
keeping devices cool that's because
diamonds naturally diffuse heat in fact
it's the best conductor of heat that we
know but these are not your average mind
these are synthetic diamonds produced in
lamps we take a substrate material so
this is something like a silicon carrier
wafer just a blank material that we want
to put the diamond on top of we put that
inside of a microwave plasma reactor
inside the reactor methane and hydrogen
gases are combined under intense
pressure to form the diamond which then
bond to the surface of a silicon wafer
because diamonds both natural and
synthetic are so strong they can be
formed into incredibly durable but
remarkably thin layers the end process
is to cut off the wafer into these
discreet little chips which you package
and those are our electronics we're
making the existing materials and
devices that we enjoy every day more
energy-efficient more thermally
efficient utilizing less materials
producing less waste but also generating
and developing the next generation of
technology the first diamond based
products will be hitting stores as soon
as in the next 12 to 24 months but while
we'll see a great improvement in size
and performance the change in price
won't be as substantial the biggest
misconception about diamond technology
really is the cost they've done a very
good job in construing diamond as a
luxury item it's a very costly item when
really it's that costs include things
like the gas in our case methane gas
methane is actually one of the most
abundant molecules in the universe but
the cost benefits aren't just limited to
consumers and small electronics about
50% of costs associated with big data
you know the computer the engine of the
internet or just on the cooling side
that means the amazons and apples of the
world are spending a lot of money just
to keep their servers and your data cool
but they could see huge reductions in
operating costs over the next few years
as diamonds become more common in
electronic systems being able to make
devices that are thousands of times more
thinner millions of times more powerful
handle paper loads of data very very
important for not only addressing
today's problems but for continuing
tomorrow's electronics last year a con
Technologies was able to charge a
diamond enabling it to conduct
electricity and giving us the potential
to make our devices much smaller and
much more powerful it's an old story in
technology there are limits and then
there's a new technology which bursts
right through those limits opening up an
entire world of possibilities